[Music]
what does it mean to love in freedom the
simple idea is it's friendship
versus marital prison
does that mean you all can have
other partners but you just have to be
respectful with each other so people
only think in terms of sex people are
trying to put something on it will and
jada they what they what they doing with
other people yeah right will and jada
ain't really doing too much or nothing
the goal is
not a sexual
goal we're going to love each other no
matter what what will gets right to the
heart of their non-traditional marriage
during the oprah conversation will smith
out today on apple tv plus the couple
first revealed details last year on red
table talk which coined a new term i got
into a different kind of entanglement an
entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes was that hard for
you sitting there
no
no how long were you all actually
separated was it months or years we
never
actually like
officially separated we agreed
that she had to make herself happy
and i had to make
myself happy and then we were going to
present ourselves back to the
relationship we ride together we go
together
bad marriage for life
it's a far cry from the start of their
relationship in his new memoir titled
will out tuesday he writes quote we
drank every day and had sex multiple
times every day for four straight months
there were only two possibilities i was
going to satisfy this woman sexually or
i was going to die trying those early
days were spectacular it turned it ended
up being a lot more complex than that
[Music]